[Music]
Welcome to My ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on right
now it's all about making it easy
[Music]
making it easy for yourself in the
kitchen means using the time you have
effectively and the one thing that can
really help you do that is your freezer
[Music]
my recipe for meatballs is so versatile
it can be used to make a dozen amazing
dishes one of my favorites is meatballs
in fragrant coconut broth
having a freezer of home-cooked
delicious food ready to go can be a real
life saver it means you never have to
compromise on Flavor these meatballs are
delicious but more importantly they
freeze so well
first off get your pan on and start
sweating off the onions and your garlic
this recipe involves making the
meatballs a classic way but the exciting
part is actually cook them in coconut
milk and it gives a really nice new
dimension to a sort of soft Rich
Sumptuous meatball
chop the onion nice and finely keeping
those slices very close together close
to the slices the finer the onions
cut it back down at an angle slice down
and just chop I want the onions nice and
fine because I want some finesse to
these meatballs The Secret of a really
good meatball is the texture
getting that balance right
between the minced beef the bread crumbs
the milk
and the seasoning a couple of cloves of
garlic slice of garlic really nice and
thinly
nice pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil quite generous available
onions and garlic in a little touch of
salt and pepper
with your mince open it up a little bit
and sort of cut it out that salt
and pepper
for me a good meatball is all about the
the softness the texture of that Rich
beef
and the way it sort of melts in your
mouth you can color it on the outside
but you want it nice and soft and sort
of rich in the center mix that in
beautifully
and then place it back out again I've
got some really nice dried chili flakes
I'm going to season the onions with the
chili flakes chili flakes in
cook that out for two minutes
I'm gonna add some milk
[Music]
take your breadcrumbs make a little well
three four tablespoons of milk that
makes it sort of nice slightly doughy
texture but it lightens the texture of
the meatball
place that in
add your onions your garlic and your
chili in there as well
nice put your hands in there and start
mixing them
if you've got the right amount of milk
and breadcrumbs it doesn't mean binding
with an egg
don't make them too small
the problem with making them too small
is the fact that they dry out quickly
just size of a golf ball
a little bit bigger
nice
give him a really nice tight squeeze
that stops IT from breaking up
it always pays to double the recipe and
spend a bit more time making extra
meatballs so you can freeze a batch
ready for another time give the pan a
little wipe out
don't wash out that pan we've got that
flavor from the onions the garlic at the
bottom look at that pan nice and hot
Taste of olive oil in there
place them
the top of your pan
nice and gently
set them in the oil get a palette knife
and go underneath them and just sort of
tilt the pan and let the pan cook the
back of the meatball we're going to add
some heat coriander seeds slightly spicy
and peppery because they give a really
nice flavor to the coconut milk in next
some cardamom seeds three or four onto
the board knife on
in a little touch of turmeric into the
center of the pan that's going to give
it a really nice spicy flavor
a little pinch cinnamon
all the time you're doing this those
meatballs are just getting tastier and
tastier a couple of dried chilies let
them Infuse in that oil
and then some lemongrass just take the
back of your knife and sort of Beat It
Down that starts to release all that
lovely sort of fragrance like someone's
just let off the most amazing fragrant
air freshener in for the lemongrass
finally some fresh ginger
peel
it's nice nice and thinly
time now
turn them over
and let the other half for a wonderful
flavor
to stop
in
bring the stock up to the boil turn the
gas up and then add the coconut milk
and I want the coconut milk just sitting
underneath the top of a meatball
coconut milk in
and that sort of
gives it that creamy richness but it's
not heavy it's a fragrant light richness
before we start simmering check the
seasoning
that nice soft texture of the meatball
but that fragrance light richness of the
coconut broth it's going to cook those
meatballs perfectly
bring the broth up to the boil
and simmer gently for eight to ten
minutes
touch them with your finger they should
be slightly pliable but slightly springy
gas off and finish it off with something
light and fresh zest of lime I don't
want the zest
on top of the meatball
sort of cut through that richness and
then finally
squeeze fresh lime
and that just gives it that nice zesty
amazing taste
stirring the juice
[Music]
it's got that kick and that vibrant
taste now the exciting part
when you come to serve it be generous
with that coconut broth
talk the pan
get a good couple of ladles of a broth
in
meatball
[Music]
and that is a very
delicious way of eating a old-fashioned
meatball and bringing it into the 21st
century and they're just as good cooked
from Frozen as well
[Music]
the secret to stress-free cooking is
making it easy for yourself here are
three more recipes all based on my
delicious freezer friendly meatballs
just defrost them before you get started
first up beef meatballs with ariketti
kale and pine nuts
[Music]
the hot oil
Brown
meanwhile cook origetti pasta
then add chopped garlic to the meatballs
and shredded kale a delicious green veg
packed with vitamins which Cooks in
minutes
cabbage is a great alternative if you
can't get kale
put in some of the cooking water from
the pasta to steam through
when the pasta is cooked al dente drain
and add to the meatballs season
then finish with sweet buttery pine nuts
and grated fresh Parmesan cheese
meatballs with other Kitty kale and pine
nuts from meatballs to meal in minutes
my next easy standby supper is beef
meatball sandwich with melting
mozzarella and tomato salsa
[Music]
top a lightly Toasted Roll with
pan-fried meatballs then tear up chunks
of creamy buffalo mozzarella pile it on
and melt it under the grill
for the Tangy salsa sliced sweet red
onion then add juicy diced tomatoes and
roughly chopped fresh coriander
Eason and drizzle with olive oil
spoon over
[Music]
perfect in a Flash beef meatball
sandwich with melting mozzarella and a
tomato salsa a sandwich to die for
[Music]
my final super easy meatball recipe is
fiery meatball soup
[Music]
foreign
chopped onion and finely slice garlic in
hot olive oil
cumin seeds for warmth
and add your meatballs
cook on a high heat to get all those
aromatic flavors out
once the meatballs are browned add hot
chili paste for a spicy kick
tinned tomatoes
dried oregano and a liter of beef stock
[Music]
then simmer
next add sweet corn
and chopped courgettes
[Music]
to finish add hot jalapeno peppers chop
fresh coriander and crushed tortilla
chips
and pop meatball wonder that really
packs a punch fiery meatball soup
[Music]
one versatile meatball recipe four
deliciously different dishes food that's
certain to make your life in the kitchen
easier and stress-free amazing whether
you're making great food to freeze or to
take straight to the table you need to
know how to shop for the best
ingredients
next up my shopping guide to oils
it doesn't matter if you're baking
frying or dressing salads using the
right oil can dramatically alter The
Taste and texture
here are the most common oils and what
to use them for
sunflower oil is a good value
all-rounder nice and light for frying
bacon in dressings and spicy dishes
ground nuts or peanut oil is great for
cooking on high heat as it gets really
hot without burning
sesame oil I flavoursome sweet and nutty
oil perfect sprinkled over Asian dishes
before serving
rapeseed oil is a healthier choice for
using in salads
I love walnut oil fantastically fragrant
it's brilliant for salad dressings and
it gives cakes a distinctive flavor
oil I use most in my cooking is olive
oil
[Music]
to find some of the best olive oils sold
in Britain get to go to one of the most
unlikely places
an electrical shop in London's East End
[Music]
turkish-born Mehmet morat has olive oil
in his blood my families produce this
olive oil for centuries what he doesn't
know about it isn't worth knowing
the very best extra virgin olive oil is
first cold pressed it's actually pressed
by Stone and then it's put for a
centrifugal spinner which spins out all
the bitter Waters and then you've got
your pure olive oil cold pressed olive
oil and you've got to taste it to
believe it
pour a little sample
slurp it draw it in without don't
swallow it warm it in your mouth coat
the whole of the inside of your mouth
with it and then swallow it will go down
like fruit juice and it will leave no
grease in a solar oiliness in your mouth
whatsoever
absolutely Sensational beautiful
my favorite use of any olive oils is to
pour it into a bowl room temperature rub
some wild oregano into it and get some
fresh busty bread and just dip it
there's food on its own don't need
anything else
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course
next are my guide to making it easy I'll
be creating a sweet treat to drool over
I want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around but first
my quick guide to the basic kit you need
to get cooking fantastic food
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment here are
three more Kitchen Essentials
whisk spoon and spatula
these three items are so cheap yet they
are so important to Great home cooking
a whisk there's so much more control
when you've got something whisking in
your hand you can gauge it so much
better than you can if it's an electric
mixer
bigger the balloon on your hand whisk
the faster it will whip as it draws in
more air Wooden Spoons don't scratch
pans they should be washed by hand
spatulas are indispensable for baking or
mixing make sure it's heat resistant so
it doesn't melt but more importantly
phenomenal for making
omelettes great with scrambled eggs and
you waste nothing because the spatula
almost cleans the bowl instantly
with these three you'll be well on your
way to cooking like a pro
and you'll need all three for my next
recipe
[Music]
my take on classic chocolate brownies is
guaranteed to put a smile on anyone's
face and not just when they're fresh out
of the oven
blondies
stock up on these delicious blondies
they'll keep for up to a week and it's a
great way of getting ahead if you're
expecting guests around
first off melt the butter for the
mixture
we've had hundreds and hundreds of
brownies the sort of white chocolate
version I.E blondies are amazing a
little bit more subtle keep a little
knob of butter
for the end just to grease your baking
tray turn the gas down
gently melt that butter
sugar into the bowl
[Music]
let's give that butter a little whisk
it sort of makes the mixture a bit
lighter slightly fluffy
off with the gas
a pinch of salt in the sugar then make a
little well in the middle
and sort of whisk you can see
it's already gone nice and blunt
love it
give that a really good mix
and the secret with the butter be
slightly warm sort of it melts the sugar
lovely
a teaspoon of vanilla extract in
next lightning whisk in two whole eggs
let's give it a little beat
this is such a delicious recipe yeah
it's so simple whisking the eggs looking
for that nice sort of rich
text just smooth paste
see why we call these blondies beautiful
next teaspoon of baking powder baking
powder in
half a teaspoon of baking soda
aerates the mixture it gives it that
little tartness you'll see the sort of
Rise instantly in a minute they hit the
oven
and then your flour whisk with one hand
and just
slowly add half the flour first
get that all mixed up make sure that
mixture is really nice and smooth
check it occasionally
no lumps half a flour in
and then the other half and you'll feel
it sort of almost go nice and firm
and that's why it's so important to add
the flowering stages this stops the
mixture going lumpy it should be just
dropping off the Whisk
beautiful
change over from a whisk to a spoon
next I want some texture some nice sweet
chewiness to the blondies dried
cranberries they bake beautifully but it
gives the Blondie a really nice sort of
chewy sweetness in the center next and
white chocolate
[Music]
I'm not going to grate it just chop it
up just slice it like little bits of
shrapnel
I want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around
now chocolate in lovely fold that in I
want a nice even distribution of those
wonderful dried cranberries
don't over mix it I want to break up
that chocolate
a nice even mix of cranberries and
chocolate
see the chocolate there'll be parts of
the chocolate in the oven that will
actually melt it'll be like little pools
of white melted chocolate in the center
now baking tray
small little knob of butter
and the grease baking tray and line it
some greaseproof paper and just over
extend it
shiny side out dull side hits the bottom
of the tray in
creased proof allows me to maximize on
the white chocolate inside the mix my
grease with paper the chocolate can melt
and almost stick to the tray so the
paper is just a really nice insurance
policy secondly we want that rise and
that sort of crispness now with the mix
get your spatula go all the way around I
don't see anything left in that bowl
position the ball over your tray
nice and carefully
don't leave that slice in the bowl
nobody's licking that one and then just
take the back of a spatula go into the
corners push and come back into the
middle
turn the tray around let it work to your
advantage
try and get it evenly positioned in the
tray
if it goes in even
it Cooks evenly
make sure you smooth out the top of the
Blondie with the back of the spatula
and then into the oven it's going to
rise it's nice and crisp
on that soft gooiness in the center
make your blondies at 180 degrees for 35
to 40 minutes
foreign
Edge on the outside and that sort of
soft gooey Center
leave that to cool down and it's going
to sort of firm up and wrinkle but it'll
stay nice and gooey in the center once
it's cooled down take it out and start
slicing
[Music]
after watching blondies a fantastic easy
treat to have on hand for yourself or to
share
[Music]
tricks of the trays and kitchen tips
to make your life easier make sure you
make the most of your freezer my tip for
amazing tuna carpaccio is to freeze it
first and it will slice beautifully
why is this safe leftover wine for
cooking my tip is to freeze the
remaining wine and freezer bags or ice
cube trays it's great in stocks and
sauces
when you freeze soups or stews in tubs
the tip is not to overfill them leave
room to expand in the container
great tip for a cheap homemade ice cream
by a high quality vanilla ice cream and
make it your own by mixing in berries
chocolate or my favorite rum and boozy
raisins
[Music]
a fantastic tip for leftover lemons and
limes is to cut them into wedges freeze
and use them like ice cubes they won't
water down your drink and they'll also
add flavor
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips 100 recipes to stay your life
on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
Welcome to My ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on right
now it's all about stress-free cooking
big dishes in advance is a brilliant way
of taking the stress out of cooking at
home and many dishes just get better and
better with time
first up
amazing sticky pork ribs one of the
secrets to Great cooking is patience
leaving dishes to marinate for one or
two days helps to develop the flavor in
your food and the end result so much
more delicious it's a method I use in
the restaurants all the time
first off get your roasting tray put the
tray on the gas pork ribs 60 meat and 35
40 fat give them a really good season so
and pepper nice thing about this cut
they stay incredibly moist when they're
on the bone and the longer you cook them
the more delicious they become just push
all that seasoning in to the pork olive
oil in
make sure that tray is nice and hot
and I really want that nice sort of
caramelization taking place on the pork
that's the nice thing about starting it
on top of the stove use your roasting
tray get them colored and then in the
oven putting the ribs straight in the
oven
you don't get the color it looks sort of
boiled as opposed to a nice caramelized
rib Ginger
you can't beat fresh ginger with sticky
pork ribs
place it down nice and firmly and slice
the thinner you slice the ginger
the more fragrant the ribs
garlic
and it's really important before you add
anything to those ribs make sure we've
got the color and the ribs first don't
rush it
turn them over that's what I want
a nice crispy color
as they sort of raise in the oven all
that color just turns into the most
amazing flavor Brazil it's just a chef's
term for cooking something slowly in
liquid
right ginger and garlic in spread it
around on all those ribs to sort of
roast the ginger and the garlic chili
flakes chili flakes in next Szechuan
pepper citrusy vibrant peppercorns
incredible in
next star anise that gives it a really
nice sort of aniseedy flavor almost like
you're roasting the ribs in fennel then
now we've got the heat we've got the
spice I want to sweeten things up a
little bit some fresh honey
glazes to Pork beautifully counteracts
against all that Spice in there oh look
what's happening color on the ribs is
extraordinary it's like a really nice
chili sweet caramel now
soy sauce brings that little bit of sort
of saltiness to it really generous with
the soy sauce
Japanese vinegar two tablespoons of
vinegar in rice wine
it gives it that nice sort of tartness
to the ribs if you can't find rice wine
a dry sherry is a great substitute
300 mil
that takes out the heat of that Szechuan
pepper those dried chili flakes make
sure they're all laid down like a nice
tight box of matches bring that up to
the boil cooking is all about learning
to develop your own likes and dislikes
so always keep tasting to make sure
you're happy with a combination of
flavors
slacking a little touch of vinegar
on that sharpness now I think what's
going on the tartness the heat the
caramel the color on the ribs is amazing
I want a bit of a sort of oniony flavor
I'll put some spring onions in
whilst these ribs are in the oven the
spring onions will sort of puree they
give a sharpness the final taste of that
pork
in in my spring onions
and with my stock
400 mL of stock
this is just a simple chicken stock the
stock just sits underneath the ribs it
absorbs into the rib and the top of the
rib glazes underneath the rib and gets
crispy and Rich and that's what makes
the ribs nice and moist really important
into the oven
cook at 180 for 30 minutes
then turn the ribs over and cook for a
further 30 minutes
[Music]
now
wow they smell incredible each side has
got that really nice crispy roasted Edge
becomes sticky and chewy and sweet sour
the fat disappeared and the pork just
melts in your mouth I want to take them
to the next level gas back on now
shake the tray
and this is the sort of the way that we
finish them in the restaurant but every
minute
they glaze in that tray they just get to
taste better and better
now look at them
I'm so happy with those
ribs done absolutely delicious now but
if you want you can put them in the
fridge and the flavor will keep
developing then just reheat them when
you want to serve
so
piece rib has a nice slice of Ginger on
there
[Music]
wow look at that
delicious sticky ribs
with an amazing marinade
to make my food the tastiest it can be I
always start with the best ingredients I
can find and the secret to getting the
best is simple
knowledge is crucial the more you know
about where your ingredients come from
and how they produce the better so ask
lots of questions and learn
when it comes to buying pork you can't
do any better than ask a butcher and
award-winning Master butcher Danny
lidgate knows everything about the pig
from Trotter to tail his family have
been in the meat business for 150 years
so this man really is on the money
in comparison with other meats Paul
from the
Trotter down to the cheek we can see
here we've got the leg the leg is about
this region
really lean really good for things like
gammons and hams coming down from the
leg we've got the loin and that's where
the pork chops come from if you take the
bones out you can bone and roll it and
you end up with a really nice easy to
cook cylinder of meat really easy to
carve carve like a loaf of breads
coming away from the loin we've got the
belly and you can see where belly is
made up of fatty parts and Meaty Parts
don't be scared of the amount of fat
that's on it you need that fat to give
give the flavors coming through also
make sure you can possibly buy it with
the skin on the skin will Crispen up
nicely give you a good crackling also
add flavor into the fat
lower down from the bellies we've got
the shoulders
really the shoulders are a great meet
they're slightly fattier than the rest
of the animal you can see with this pork
shoulder the amount of marble you're
getting the mussels the interior
marbling make sure you look for the
marbling it's essential for the flavor
and it's going to make a really good
eating experience
I think there really is nothing to waste
the truss is even a really good flavor
because they're gelatinous qualities and
the meat can be really really
flavoursome also there's Pig's cheeks
which obviously require a little bit
more cooking because of the use they get
but the flavors you're going to get are
going to be completely different to any
other part of a pig
pork is an incredibly versatile mate
they say the only part you can't eat is
the Oink
here's my guide to getting the best out
of familiar cuts
smoked or unsmoked bacon is not just for
breakfast it's brilliant transforming
salads gives a real depth of flavor to
stews and is delicious in quick and easy
pasta dishes
[Music]
the leg joint best known for ham also
makes an inexpensive delicious Sunday
roast and is great served with peas
pudding
and the tenderloin fillet incredibly
lean healthy and fast to cook you can
stuff it cut it into scallops or strips
that are perfect for Asian stir fries
[Music]
a calm kitchen is an efficient and
effective kitchen the less stressed you
are the better the food you'll produce
so whenever you can get ahead with your
cooking here are three of my favorite
recipes they've been made beforehand
whose flavor improves over time
foreign
Lamb with sweet potato and raisin
[Music]
this super simple hassle-free recipe is
cooked all in one pot start by Browning
chunks of lamb in hot olive oil
color and remove
then fried onions
season
add chopped garlic ground ginger and
coriander
a teaspoon of whole cumin seeds
paprika and fennel seeds
a cinnamon stick bay leaf and delicate
strands of saffron then fry to release
all the aromatic flavors next add tomato
puree chunks and sweet potato and the
juicy Brown lamb
for a sweet note add plump raisins then
cover with stock and simply leave to
simmer for a couple of hours
delicious eaten straight away but over
time the flavors will develop and
improve
when you're ready to serve simply finish
with fresh parsley
minimal preparation and ready when you
want it fantastic Moroccan Lamb with
sweet potato and raisin
my next super simple dish that just gets
better and better with time is chili
chicken with ginger and coriander
[Music]
by chopping chicken thighs into pieces
now on with the marinade
chopped garlic
Ginger red chili
and lemon juice
[Music]
in a pan toast coriander and cumin seeds
to release their flavors grind and add
to the chicken
[Music]
then pour over plain yogurt add turmeric
and seasoning
mix and leave to marinade from two hours
to overnight
next fry chopped onions in olive oil
then add chopped garlic and ginger
ground coriander garam masala
and turmeric
tomato puree and butter
next add the marinated chicken and all
the remaining marinade and cook until
tender finally top with coriander
marinated for flavor and cooked in 20
minutes chili chicken with ginger and
coriander a simple stress-free wander
having a delicious sauce on hand to
serve with simply cooked fish or meat is
a brilliant stress Buster my final
recipe is sweet pepper sauce with
grilled prawns
[Music]
for the sauce in hot olive oil fried
chopped garlic and diced bread
[Music]
and put them in a blender
[Music]
add chopped tomatoes
[Music]
blister the skin of red peppers under a
Hot Grill intensifying the flavor
leave to cool then they're easy to peel
chop and add Blitz
add smoked paprika chili flakes and
roughly chopped almonds
squeeze of lemon and a dash of Sherry
vinegar
season
Blitz again and add olive oil
this sauce keeps really well in the
fridge and will intensify in flavor
I love it with simple King prawns just
add olive oil
and Gretel for two minutes on each side
[Music]
sweet pepper sauce with grilled prawns
Simply Delicious
[Music]
made in advance ready when you want them
three stunning simple recipes that take
the stress out of the kitchen beautiful
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stay your life on I'll be
showing you an amazing spicy Chutney
that's brilliant for transforming the
simplest of suppers
they don't actually smell much but the
flavor they give off is extraordinary
but first five more of my 100 tips to
make your home cooking easier
kicking off with how to skin and debone
a fish the hassle-free way
interestingly Affiliated side of salmon
it's been taken off the bone and now
skin off
pick up your knife a really nice broad
flexible
knife
a little sharpen lift up
the base of the towel and then just Nick
a little bit at the end there twist the
knife almost as if it's horizontally
underneath the salmon cool the skin and
you slice
the salmon underneath and let the knife
do the work now get your skin
flip it back over and check you're not
leaving too much salmon on top of the
skin pull it back
and nice and slowly get the skin wrap
around your fingers
pull the salmon towards you and then
just all the way through
lay that down
one nicely skinned salmon just like a
perfect snake skin
get your knife and just run the Knife
Down
and then the pair of tweezers these are
fish tweezers but you can use normal
tweezers
look for the head up
and Pull and with the skin being removed
from underneath the salmon
the pin Bones come out a lot easier
and the pinballs only go to just
basically halfway
along the fillet
one nice fillet of salmon beautiful
there's still plenty of flavor in the
trimmings from Affiliated fish my tip is
don't waste those fish bones add to
water wine a bay leaf and some chopped
veg to make a simple but versatile fish
stock at home the perfect base for a
delicious fish soup
[Music]
a great tip for intensely flavored
stress-free veg is to steam them in
their own juices simply add to a pan
with a knob of butter and seasoning then
cook on a low heat with a lid on to lock
in the moisture
[Music]
for crispy roast potatoes you can depend
on my tip is to parball them leave them
to steam dry then sprinkle them with
semolina or flour and give them a good
roughing up this ensures they go really
crispy in the oven
a great tip for Browning meat or fish is
to drive with kitchen roll before you
cook it then you'll get a much better
color too much moisture makes the meat
steam instead of sear and you'll lose
that rich brown crust like the one I got
on those sticky pork ribs
foreign
taking the stress out of cooking is to
anticipate the really busy times when
you'll need things to hand that are
already made
my next recipe can be kept on tap in the
fridge for weeks on end and is
guaranteed to liven up any quick meal
spicy chutney
with Chutney standing by in the fridge
you can always add that special little
touch to a simple supper prove that
thinking ahead always pays off
pan on to start toasting those spices
keep the pan nice and low cumin very
aromatic very fragrant and it's almost
like a light spice
next little coriander seeds coriandering
now you're going to get a bit of heat in
the Chutney mustard seeds well smaller
than coriander seeds but so much more
powerful mustard seeds in
now Curry leaves they don't actually
smell much dry but the flavor they give
off is extraordinary code is in
really important not to burn them
otherwise you'll have that bitter taste
across the Chutney keep the gas nice and
low the secret is sort of toasting them
so it releases that oil and intensifies
the spice Touch of salt
and then a couple of small powerful
chilies keep them whole no one's going
to eat them but it gives that real nice
burst of heat
now let them toast gently there we're
not going to chop the onion we're going
to grate it
why
because it sort of breaks down to a
really nice puree in the Chutney when
you grate it hold the root in the palm
of your hand and just push
nice long
straight
I want those nice long shards
look I've almost got a nice sort of
onion puree but it's nice and clear
Touch of olive oil
spices nicely toasted onions in
[Music]
three nice cloves of garlic
crush them
[Music]
lay it nice and flat and just slice the
garlic nice thin slices
garlic in
taking your time to get the owners
caramelized beautifully will really reap
rewards in the long run
Tamarind place and sugar in with the
sugar first three nice tablespoons of
sugar
that will give a really nice syrup
effect a sort of nice rich syrupy
texture to the chutney
Tamarind paste
you can get Tamarind paste in most delis
and the big supermarkets
it's really nice thickening agent but it
gives that tartness a Chutney and its
sort of bridge sugary spicy
next in with my coconut add four nice
tablespoons that will give a nice body a
really nice texture to the Chutney cut
that coconut out and now add the carrot
grated
the carrot just gives the Chutney a
really nice sort of punch
but also helps to sort of cool down the
spice
carrots in
the water comes out of the carrot
flavors the Chutney beautifully but
gives that nice sort of vibrant bright
color to it as well
and grating it almost sort of it Cooks
instantly but I want a bit of texture
through here turn down the gas and just
let that simmer for five minutes
because the cars are that moist and
juicy then put a couple of tablespoons
of water in there to help it along
now
let's cook that out for five minutes
just so those carrots start going nice
and soft don't overcook them you want
that nice texture in there slightly
spicy slightly sweet gas off
keep those chilies in there for that
it's beautiful nice and gooey delicious
and
ready to go in his jar because that sits
in the fridge
just gets better and better and better
I love to eat this chutney with cold
meats or even cold fish but with ham
it's amazing
it's a really nice way of livening up
the ham
just sort of roll it up
spoon of chutney
I mean it looks fantastic
Chutney onto the plate
serve and that is a nice little
gem in the fridge that is worth prepping
in advance for
cookery course crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stay your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking